[Musique]
tout le monde veut des baisses d'impôts
on aime les baisses d'impôts on est à
québec on vous demande avec les
râteliers aussi on doit baisser les
impôts ou réinvestir dans les services
d'un côté on nous dit qu'on a beaucoup
de marge de manoeuvre financière
vous êtes un travailleur
oui vous payez des impôts oui de l'autre
on nous dit qu'il ya un vieillissement
de la population très important la
population active baisser alors est ce
qu'ils font presser les ait aujourd'hui
et je tiens on va être obligé de les
remonter plus tard dans les prochaines
générations parce qu'on va se rendre
compte qu'on est trop serré sur le plan
fiscal au québec
qu'est ce qu'on fait avec le surplus et
écouter ses montres les impôts j'ai
l'impression que ça se passe plus haut
quatre ans que au niveau des générations
mais je pense que c'est mieux de
contribuer
sans arrêt parce que ça va nous revenir
un peu au visage avec le mode de vie
qu'on a
faut-il donc baisser les impôts
aujourd'hui et en éducation
quel est le bon choix c'est sûr qu'on en
veut toujours plus mais je pense que
ceux des services qui sont clairement
mon enfant d'avoir à vivre des solutions
à court terme s'est jamais la bonne
solution faut passer un petit peu plus
seul à londres
bonjour madame suppose une petite
question d'aller travailler
oui j'en ai plus probable mais c'est ce
qu'ils vont nous rattrape toujours de
toute façon ok ben c'est peut-être un
point c'est sûr mais je pense c'est plus
une question de la clause sociale puisse
avantager différentes personnes comme
chez les libéraux la caq souhaite une
réduction d'impôt au pq et québec
solidaire on prend davantage un
réinvestissement dans les services
honnêtement je réinvestis sur toi
d'éducation c'est vraiment déplacé un
problème legault justement qui peuvent
payer de l'impôt aujourd'hui ben ça
ferait une différence beaucoup plus
marquants
[Musique]